hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't play this game now
I'm going to go play this game because
I'm a simple guy when he dies from the
fact I don't know which person poster
Musti why don't you grew on it same
Fulton as ever
hover the tablecloth punch
do you understand me no not at all he
does okay listen there's the buttons at
the door should i Garris him I know I'm
grump Friel what what is that's the game
what am I supposed to remember that
there's a guarantor door should you go
arrest him I don't know what the [ __ ]
just happened
hang on everybody I need to I need to I
need to reset my brain because I have no
idea what the hell just happened oh my
god okay listen again sure you last in
the fights I don't know me Tristan pokes
- Musti I lied I still only grew on it
same fortune as ever
hover the tablecloth hunt do you
understand me
nobody does you I do behind us there's
the buttons at the door should i Garris
him there's a bargains at the door are
you grant real
Bikram what about Bear Grylls 2:38 of
780 I don't know what you're doing to me
what is tisk limit Africa's look it's
Canada kwon do well what does that mean
so are any of you guys writing this down
because I feel like there's got to be a
quiz at the end of this - no I didn't
know that we're going to get on
ourselves into the SATs here but here we
go again from the photos no Mitch for
long hopes to let my fart on fire don't
you cruel um it I eat my gruel every day
same old janessa
ah Folgers the best part of waking up
April quoth pump aha punt the tablecloth
got it do you understand me I think I do
I'm naked he does I do listen that's the
Bulge ins up the door okay there's
Chennai ever heard or should you
function youth grow Gary you find you a
game grump the 780 okay let's just
concentrate on the numbers that it's
given me here the 780 might be the sheer
number of letters in the phrase that
whatever the hell that demon spawn is
saying so if we think about it that way
we're only getting 232 of the correct
letters out of that is that an
understandable way to go about this or
is that going about it the wrong way
what happens if I quit
okay men huh well that's dumb for me
because that is that's not what I was
aiming for let's try it again I'm gonna
go back in here I'm gonna go back in I
don't know how to play this game cuz who
the Frick knows what that all is let's
give her a listen
q last from the fight I don't know major
stand close to my oh why don't you cruel
megamum pickin among them same old
chicken
it's a little dry to stop picking up
animals again we got known into a farce
Erica - Lewis Quebec I'm gonna write
down what this person saying I'm gonna
write down the words it may take me a
few goes mom try to write it down maybe
I can make sense of it that way you'll
abide in the fact I don't know which for
simple after motioning
why don't you grew on it same told you
never palpable Hale caught hunt do you
understand me
nobody does listen there's a bhajan at
the door should i Garris him find me a
crumb Friel he lands in the fact I don't
know where it is imposed enough see why
don't you rule on it same same folding
as ever
hover the tablecloth hunt do you
understand me nobody does
listen there's the buttons at the door
should i Garris him find me wrong real
199 VIN k2 climb aboard damn normal
with new book I don't know what this is
you learn fact I don't know whispers in
boasting why don't you blue line say
forever
[Music]
okay I have no idea I have absolutely no
idea what to do with this there's no
other information being given to be it's
the same words every time so it's not
like the words are changing I really
don't know what to do about this so I'm
going to leave it up to you guys so I
know it says don't play this game but
I'm going to put a link down the game
below and hopefully you guys are going
to be able to solve the mystery but be
careful not to lose your mind while
you're diving down that hole so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know your thoughts down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye